but when you say mental breakdown what
happens so basically what happened was
my show ended numbers ended I didn't
know who I was anymore I didn't know
what my career was I got married and the
very next day I flipped the I
flipped out we booked uh our honeymoon
the next morning in St Barts beautiful
place except we went during the off seon
so everything was closed I got like
Island fever and that's how the nervous
breakdown sort of started the anxiet
then turned into really deep paralyzing
depression I I became agoraphobic I
couldn't leave the house and it went on
for nine months it was a full nine
months right after you get married and
right after my show ends which was a big
successful show yeah so my my wife God
bless her was just like who is this
person and you tricked me you basically
you tricked me